hi everyone so I get a lot of questions
from the viewers that how to qualify
I teach em and how to study for that we
were to study for that what are the best
resources that one can use
so I teach em is entrance examination
for postgraduate degrees in Indian
Institute of Technology's and some in
IPS so in I invite each m.i.b champ our
technology the subject wittich are
divided into four parts
it has 44% biology 20% chemistry 18%
physics and maths respectively now for
all these subjects
there are several resources that can be
used and that could save over time
and we can use those resources to study
in a smart way and if you are like me
don't study em Leslie we need to study
less but you need to serve this smart so
there are some do's and don'ts but I
want to say so first of all the basic
concept in biology should be very very
clear and we should not spend too much
time on biology and not even studying
chemistry or maths or anything like that
because chemistry maths and physics
together contributes more than the
biology here in this exam so every day
we should practice a little bit amount
of math because most of the biology is
to forgive the normal form form you
doesn't anything in the math so that's
why we should give more time on that and
restrict a specific time of our day
towards them so here are some basic
books most popular books that one can
use to clear the concepts for example
for molecular biology
I used to use molecular biology of gene
for a biochemistry one the best resource
could be the dangerous power industry
and Prescott's mark microbiology is one
of the classic take us books for macro
but the shortcut is to use this instant
bias New York's books so these are books
by garland science publications so they
they actually sell these books and you
can get this book from Amazon and
Flipkart or whatever you want and these
books are really thin and these books
has all the necessary information and
high-heat material that one can use so
for shortcut I use these books as well
and there are some good books from where
we can practice the MCQs and it also
encompasses the previous year question
so solving previously a question is most
important so we should not study
aimlessly like reading and reading
reading all the basic concepts so what I
think is what we can do is first take a
chapter and see from that chapter how
much question comes in the question
paper in last 10 years and what type of
questions are asked and based on that we
can build our study to be in our
strengths way of study two books which
can give you a final touch before one
month of exam is the Pathfinder likes
and series 1 and series 2 so these books
are all played and for maths or physics
or any other thing where mostly they ask
plus two level questions so I use these
mathematics or chemistry or physics in
14 year series so these are super
trained and full of information they
also have practice tests so these books
are pretty useful for me at least
so these are the few resources that I
used to Paulo 5 champ and there are many
other ways by which you can plan your
study but these are my opinion how I can
prepare or how one can
I have another playlist where I discuss
few of the design questions and if you
like my video and find it useful please
like share among your friends and to
grow and share my video thank you